やっ
チックから帰っ俺仕事で東京にも入ってるから3こっちゃ今帰ってから実感の人たちと
か家族とか真的に移したくないんで帰ってないから
寂しもちろん肇社長です皆さんやってまいりました
もう年末に発表だったと思うんですけども a まずジャンバー
年末ジャンボ皆さん買いましたか僕はねぇ
買いました僕がしっかり買わせていただきましたよ年末ジャンボディションやったと
思うんですけど
2 tone んぱくちゃんとあのねぇ末ジャンボ右で年楽ジャンボは1等な6円
でしょうあったっけねぇんだよ
1等な老犬の年末 java てるわけないんですよおっそんな持ってないんであれは
もうね汽船のスーパースターしか当てられないあさりの方数も少ない
ら俺はそんなね夢見る少女じゃないんで僕は堅実に年末ジャンボん見に置かれました
右腰でフィゲルは恥だが役に立ちます年末ジャンボは1等がな老犬なんですけどもう
すでに少なくて年末ジャンボミニは1等が3000万円なんですけどもたくさん立てて
前後所で1000万円だから便版で当たれば5000万円母艦です
手堅いてがたいんですよねまずは右のほうが俺みたいな知的な男は年末ジャンボで
当たらないんですよななんでだからなんてもう全然文化が画一的に何年て方動画年末所
の目に分かりました
逃げましたでネイルは茶の面だけ言うと1頭が3000万円前後賞が1000万円に等
でも5万円当たるんですよ
で北南へ向かったといいますとぽじあもうあさあぞ
万円です
違うわかるわかる俺の買った趣旨としてはあたりに行きたいじゃないんですよあのお金
をかけずに当てて楽したい少ない投資で高鼾を求める3万円向かったから
未到の5万円でても2万円の後になるんですよゲル法これで5万円たってて3投後
舞い上がってるプラン大丈夫なんてあ嬉しい気持ち失いマンなら10万円払って2頭が
1本5万円しか出なかったなぁ
ですお前何で魅せろそうしてですよ悲しい思いはしたくねぇようで2等が出た瞬間
2万円のメリットになる
3万円分買わせていただきましたいいですか安い通して利益を見ましょう
宜山さっそく見ていきましょうパラと年版買いました分かるこのたから来てあ
ナーセリー舌の下を姉じゃないんですよがんばって押そうとして当て水田は世界とお金
ではなく
ラック
してもうから5000万円それが欲しいんですそれがその頑張って稼いだお金だったら
さあ使うの支部だけどこんな音なんだろうかポーって5000万ぺいたらもう俺は素描
悪いけどで今回なんでこんなたからずつ動画出せるかといえばそれ今年きてる気がする
んですよ
めっちゃ当たる気がしてて今年は畑のみんなにも5000万円当たったら100万円
ずつ上げることにするのでまあまあ古泉は当たった全然車
とは言えないよねいよいよって感じでへとひとり薩摩路つだけできます場で5万円せて
2万円のプラスでしょ
服買っちゃうって楽して儲けてそれの具イングの宝くじですから年版ゴジラのバラ50
枚合計100枚でございます合計100枚で3万円分でございますさあ
5000万当てますよっ
じゃあまず後藤から行けましたが god が下1桁が6
ろくな奴だったらもう個300円でショアー300円は3300円と300
取り上げ鮫田阪すべてためペン300円300円術県まずはしっかりと後藤で
3000円ゲットしました
次いで4等が3000円ですね所もに行けたら27見ていきましょう
27でしょうね
ん
archi 追加きついな
待ってだった家も語ったあっあーっ
あの動画がはいはい下に方2727で3000円だ
じゃんっ3000円ゲットしましたこれ逆に腹で27があればもうちょい稼げるなこと
に俺持ってるみんな持ってるって思えば持ってるから2727パラちょっと苦しい
あぁさすがにワークですシーカーあーだめだねはい4道の3000が1本出ました
3 z 3000今6000円日過ぎましたね
あと24,000稼ぐんだけどここで稼ごうとさんと下3桁
結構あるんだね3等1万円ですねこれで山普通嬉しいです
見ていきます
ん
をつくっていません
n
いいよじゃああっっ
あああああ
見て三は見て見て見てまたやばいやばいやばいやばいバルーンミディやってみて
ください
お産ってた3脂肪酸系高19号です1万円なんで3棟が見てください
あ1953上一番ゲットデー
やったぁー初めてちゃんと一枚当たったってどこまで見たときこれあるぞもうすぐ元
取れるところまで落ち着け落ち着け皆様のこれ前哨戦ですよ本番はここから日東といっ
た当てて組んででも心臓が高鳴ってるぞやあよーしよしいいぞいいぞ
もう1本1枚だってよ
[音楽]
くっ
バッハ
[音楽]
ああ
まってこれ怖いぞえっと申し込みくださいへしまって下3桁らえーっと917
入ってみてください
917だねサンダー一番 get a
強い強い今日僕歌ってんだけどねっ後インターネットなんか2枚を撮りました
惜しい
さあさんと兄さんはず nerf とぴょんぴょん系
やったやったやっだべさんと日本でて2万円です
ずっとよたうれしい20,00026,000円ですね
うわぁ査察で水戸5万円です下4桁
んですねよし見ていきましょう
そうにとダメでしたじゃあ続いてはいよいよ1頭ではさっそく見ていきましょう
絶版いいから欲しい
[音楽]
奪うでしたぁーいどうならずでしたみなさん本当にやってるつもりだったんですいや
けどすごくないから3万円分買って後藤が10個手を頭が10個300円かけるぞ遺産
全4棟の3年間1万回六星でしょ
で3頭の1万円が2本出てるんでニーナ6,000円
[音楽]
ブーブー
ん
[音楽]